Puck is brought this way by Pon hands it off
Chris L Tang will rip it out to gensel gensel
steps in looks across shot by Raquel and that's
bought on it's for an overtime loss in Ottawa
on Saturday as barzell has the puck looks
across to Horvat but he'll play it out to
the line instead Riley with a shot and that
one comes through to jar h on Give It Away
here's Paul Mary behind the net right on Hugh
Puck angled out to Riley across A's one timer
is melted down by jar acquisition is here is
cek is Wheeling in couldn't get a shot off
on the back hand doson across to Romanov touch
back to him for barcel and a slap shot is into
the glove of Jar Rael ahead for Carter he'll
Rim it around Eller gets to it jumes it to lat
Tang who has space l tang with a shot knocked
down in front rebounds loose and it's knocked
Away by the pad of sokin I arogan with a big
save right here to keep the Penguins off the
board skates in and dumps to the corner down after
it is Bo Horvat Horvat to barzel he opens up in
front got a shot off the pad of Jar back to the
front and Lee moved it over to the corner as he
was trying to get it around the tank stick hand
a little too much poked Away by OK Conor he's
off ice the Thompson to beat he'll take it why
now to the front got crossed up sokin stopped
it it's still loose and sokin will melt it down
somehow doing snow angels gets the whistle good
strong move watch him he realizes he's got an
opportunity but here watch the Islanders just
all go by the by the net and and he's taken to
the glass by Graves Pon it pokes it out on for
Smith Riley Smith has Pon to the net he'll hold on
looks for the Bal that's not open and sokin makes
another stop holding on with his blove Malin gets
it behind the net AO in after it he's wrapped up
by zohorna hon in for Malin opens up he's denied
by soken puck comes back off the near wall wonder
which where he'd be if it were for the concussion
related injuries back in 2011 2012 he missed a lot
of time and his numbers are impressive already
but if he hadn't missed a lot of games those
two seasons even more impressive Pon shot block
they blew it dead before the puck got past soken
a good break there and now Sydney if you talking
about the concussion and missing the games he'd
be further down the list when the whistle blows
the place most certainly dead hear the whistle
long before yeah you could hear it there Rael no
doubt put it in but yeah you definitely hear the
whistle you can tell his reaction look at rael's
reactions telling you shouldn't have gone but no
question consultation on the ice the call is
overturned to a good ball oh they're going to
challenge that I didn't know you could do that
now be reviewed for a continuous play marzelle
looking for a way out not successful and here's
aari again lowers the shoulder spins away from
barzel the line Pon across for lank the front
this one is redirected in the penguins have a
two nothing lead on a jake gensel deflection
yeah great defense great deflection there as
lat Tang fired it that was about 2 ft outside
the post they win the battle Chari down low D
to D and watch this deflection way outside
and and really just a tremendous deflection
no chance for sokin if you're as a defenseman
you've got to get a hold of gel stick and for
me Butch it starts a long time before that what
a beautiful uh deflection that was twice the New
York Islanders defenseman the puck on their
stick know how to deliver the puck into a
spot that doesn't look dangerous but certainly
can be when you got guys like Jake gensel that
timeout brought to you by your local Honda dealer
as here's a stretch pass pass on for gel he's got
his third point of the period and his second
goal two quick ones the penguins have opened
up with three nothing lead and after a timeout
Lane Lambert has got to be steaming that quick
pass up and then gel's on a breakaway and
Romanov and and and Dobson defenseman well
got to think that was one of their men and boy
oh boy break away from the Blue Line penguin out
the Islanders pit yeah the Islanders they just
can't they can't get isolated man on man the
penguins have done a good job of switching off and
changing places here's ha between the circles he
scores and this sold out crowd was getting
frustrated and that's the cherry on top four
goals in his second period for Pittsburgh
if gny Malin with that one I mean they they
they won all the races to the corners and they
moved the puck quickly and they moved into the
holes and the Hors just couldn't find a way
you can see players jumping around back and
forth and finally malin's able to shake loose
so again that's all about communication and
talking to one another watch won come right
through beautiful pass and makes no mistake
just way too much time for skilled players
to make plays and you see what happens just
too much sitting back and I know you're in a
long shift now you're right but she signed a
three-year extension August of 2022 that'll
kick in after this season so that'll take
him to 2027 here's the front Romanov shot didn't
go all it is Sydney Crosby doesn't have a point
yet as it is pson who leaves it for of guine
Malin Pon to leang steps to it the head of
Holstrom Letang into the crease they score it's
a fiveg goal second period they have just owned
the offensive zone on the New York Islanders
in in tonight's game dominated by the by the
Penguins I mean look at the movement got got to
take these guys out too many turns around and
then good jump byang and look at the positioning
malan's just all alone in front I mean you just
got to do a better job let's watch where AO goes
he's number 25 watching watching and he's on the
outside and not the good spot to be and malan
who's so good that pass goes right through the
crease but no chance for sroi move it ahead
picks up speed as he goes in a quarterback
for barzel cross that one broken up by pon get
it back on the lead pass from lank Pon in the
bit here's a two-on one Poston and has Zorna f
it to the cras it's Jam home zohorna 6 nothing
Pittsburgh rebound play but it's a two-on-one
by the Islanders and there are going to be some
guys tonight that are going to be minus three
minus 4 as we watch this plays zah Horna goes
to the net first save by soken and the puck just
bounces down and soken not quite strong enough
but a good play by Hawkins to get it all the
way across and it's just a lot of guys minus
in this one as pu comes across gensel looking
for his third of the N didn't get it to go and
then Malin is also on hatrick watch dropped
to a knee and Raquel scored the first goal of
this game it came on a call that initially was
signal no goal and then overturn horat to the
front and that one like it got swallowed up by
jar last season at the end of last year in in
March is that thrilling 43 overtime win as zenul
drives to the net got it backand shot off that J
stopped with the glove barel to the front Nelson
and on gold jar with the save he Smothers it been
involved in the game I can't say anyone's had
a good night but yeah to your point there's a
lot of guys that had very poor nights or what's
the old thing there's some passengers out there
Thomas yeah there's a onetime for Pon in and he's
going to slam that in to make it seven nothing
Val ter Pon in scores his first National Hockey
League goal tonight the Islanders just haven't
handled it look at all three Islanders down low
on the left side and and that's just a a shot
from in a very very good good position and again
V arm offs has you know he's got to get all the
way across and that one timer um is just very
very good but that goal from valter Poon in is
first in the National Hockey League there's these
three guys up high again so let's just see how the
island handle that look out raqual shot kicked
away here are the New York Islanders a couple
of days after Christmas return from their holiday
break the sound of booze from their own fans they
lose the penguin 7 nothing and it matches
their worst home loss in franchise history